you my monkey butt lovely leather sweet
cheese funny I'm your daddy next ticket
doodle baby boo honey I'm gonna say it
again
when I started doing music it wasn't I
didn't set out to rap even my producer
at that time he said you need to spit
real about your life who you are and so
I came out to him I'm like what do you
you know I'm gay what if I spell out
that he's oh I didn't do it that's what
you got to do
I'm Joey Lamar aka deadly and I'm a
rapper and I'm a gay so baby baby I'm
yours dirty habits foul mood back in the
early 2000 when I started doing this
stuff no one had ever seen an open gate
rapper to them I was only supposed to be
like a masculine guy that's doing it and
spitting about chicks and this but I was
taking it further back with my rap I
mean I was thinking more about Public
Enemy I was a big fan of Rage Against
the Machine well I mean they can make
change with their music and that's so
that's kind of what I was doing to my
early fans were not the people who I
expected I thought it was going to be
hip-hop heads be brown and black men but
it wasn't that and it kind of made me
mad because you know I really wanted my
brown and black people that loved me and
liked what I was doing but I was dealing
with a lot of people that were down low
and they had to because that's just
whether we were brought up in the
culture they say for better for worse
the baby baby on your dirty habits
when I first came out to I thought I was
going to get a lot of love from the gay
community and it was the hardest thing
to crack and even the festivals I tried
to play long beach tried to play la
pride and every time they're like you're
a little too hardcore we don't want that
element here and I'm like but I'm gay
what element are you talking about they
don't understand that there's gay fools
that look like me and we're not gonna go
cause problems manages this is the way
we look if I tell you to love something
it's a gay love something like you said
I'm sweet man you know what I think it
just takes time you need to talk to
people and people need to look beyond
the surface man and I'm guilty of that
too man you know I think we're all
guilty it's just human nature man
I think we all want to put everyone in a
box and what's cool now - it's like dude
they're not looking at me as the game
rapper they're not trippin on the whole
gay thing and just do music